[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP on se retrouve
comme chaque semaine autour d'un plat
d'un dessert et d'un invité et cette
semaine nous recevons Stanislas Guerini
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour Stanislas Guerini
bonjour vous êtes ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique nommé depuis mai 2022 mais vous
avez été un des tout premiers de
l'aventure en marche vous rejoignez
l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron dès 2015
grâce à deux proches Ismaël émélien et
Benjamin Griveau vous faites tous partis
de la bande de la planche du nom de
cette rue du 7e arrondissement d'où sont
tous issus les DS BO mais c'est place
d'éternes dans le 17e arrondissement que
tout commence votre appartement sert de
quartier général la suite on la connaît
Emmanuel Macron est élu vous aussi
député de Paris puis patron du parti
avant de devenir ministre mais vous
gardez votre simplicité et vous n'en
oubliez pas vos origines que l'on
retrouve dans le menu du jour
Jean-Pierre en effet Brigitte un risotto
tout simple mais quel risotto le risotto
à la milanaise et en dessert une salade
de poire dans le dessous des plat le
ministère de la Fonction publique
consomme responsable nous sommes allés
vérifier en cuisine dans les pieds dans
le plat alors que la sécheresse SVIT de
plus en plus pourquoi ne pas utiliser
les eaux usées pour irriguer les
cultures la France compte bien rattraper
son retard par rapport à certains pays
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et
confidence Stanislas Guerini vous avez
été habitué tout jeune à l'excellence un
prénom de prince qui signifie gloire
rien que cela des fonds de culotte usé
sur les bans des goesaciennes et du
Lycée Henri I c'est la crème de la crème
bref lorsqu'il s'agit de partager avec
nous un plat pour rendre hommage à vos
racines italiennes pas question de pâes
au pois chiche recette tirée de la
couchina povera non vous optez
naturellement pour l'excellence le roi
des risottos un risotto à la milanaise
dont la création Brigitte remontré au
16e siècle la légende romanesque indique
que c'est l'assistant d'un riche maître
verrier qui avait l'habitude de teinter
ses vers avec du safran pour les rendre
brillants comme le doomo de Milan qui a
eu l'idée d'incorporer ses précieux
pistilLe pardon dans le riz lors du
mariage de la fille de son patron pour
lui donner cette couleur unique nacrée
et dorée comme on peut le voir et
commment on va le goûter alors depuis 5
siècles bien sûr la recette a évolué
sans cesse enrichie pour aboutir à ce
risoto divin souvent méconnu chez nous
en France mais qui fait partie sans
doute des SEP merveilles de la cuisine
italienne est-ce que vous validez ça
Stanislas d'abord vous m'apprenez
beaucoup de choses vous me donnez
vraiment envie de donner le premier coup
de fourchette dans cette dans cette
assiette alors on va le goûter commence
dans dans les actes tous ensemble c'est
vrai qu'il a une une couleur
incroyable donc il est parfaitement
réussi et c'est vrai moi c'est un un
réseoto que j'ai j'ai toujours aimé en
fait c'est c'est celui que j'ai j'ai
découvert à la maison j'ai des origines
italiennes j'avais un grand-père qui
était italien nord au sud vers Bergam ah
oui voilà donc Italie du Nord euh c'est
un grand-père moi que j'ai jamais connu
donc c'est un peu le paradoxe chez moi
parce que on a cette culture italienne
c'est mon nom c'est je me bat toujours
pour pas mettre d'accent à guerinii
parce que c'est italien il y a pas
d'accent en italien c'est Guerini et
donc c'est votre papa ou votre maman qui
est mon papa V papa et donc mon mon
grand-père qui est venu très jeune voilà
dans les les Basques de son propre papa
à lui comme beaucoup de de à
l'époque euh ils ont fu l'Italie du du
fascisme ils sont arrivés dans voyez
donc c'est deux cultures qui se qui se
marient et puis moi le paradoxe chez moi
c'est qu'on a jamais parlé italien mon
grand-père il est mort très jeune c'est
un grandpère que j'ai jamais connu qui
s'appelle Daniel et qui tenait à ce que
on parle français à la maison lui il est
venu assez jeune adolescent en France il
a travaillé très tôt et donc mon papa et
mon oncle eux n'ont jamais parler
italien à la maison et c'est plus tard
que l'Italie est revenu mais ils étaient
emprint de cette culture italienne eux
même jeune pas tant que ça t ça c'était
plutôt le Gers puis ensuite bannière de
bigor voyez donc c'était racin vraiment
très sud-ouest et puis c'est plus tard
dans ma famille par le parcours
professionnel de mon père qui a un jour
travaillé en Italie et qui a appris
l'italien lui à ce moment-là et puis
ensuite avec mon frère on a eu l'envie
de retrouver ces racines là et tout ce
qui s'y est attaché c'est vrai que à la
maison on cuisinait ce
risotto pas italien M Iten it on
mangeait italien ouais c'est vrai qu'il
y a des il y a des traces comme ça mais
c'est aussi intéressant sur ce qui est
l'immigration
l'assimilation et mon grand-père tenait
à ce que ça soit vraiment la France et
lui il avait je pense aussi une distance
vis-à-vis de l'Italie qui était pour lui
l'Italie du fascisme à ce moment-là il
avait fui et il avait envie de cette
assimilation française mais il y a
toujours des choses qui restent qui
passent au-dessus des générations et
voilà et le plat qu'on est en train de
déguster aujourd'hui plat familial des
Guerini par excellence oui moi j'ai
appris à à cuisiner très
c'est un plat qui est fantastique le le
le risotto qui prend du temps de
préparation c'est un peu le secret aussi
de de préparer minutes environ oui mais
il faut le laisser reposer il y a une
phase tous les amateurs de risotto
connaissent le mon petit truc voilà
petit truc fin puisque vous êtes très
vous avez l'air spécialiste mon caré
c'est le dernier geste ouais c'est ça
c'estàd que il faut pas se précipiter
quand on a fini de préparer le le
risotto alors il y a on a mis du
bouillon de légumes successifs et cetera
on a incorporé le safran quand c'est un
risotto à la mélanèse et puis surtout à
la fin le premier réflexe ça pourrait
être de se dire vite vite on met du
beurre du parmesan et puis puis on le
mange tout de suite erreur fatale il
faut laisser le risotto reposer dans le
plat c'est ça ce monte car ou il va
prendre et donc là toutes les matières
grasses de la fin de la cuisson du
beurre du parmesan vont
s'incorporer et vont donner voilà le ça
veut dire aussi c'est ce geste
effectivement on laisse reposer on pose
le le beurre qui doit être froid et le
parmesan sur un riz auto cha qu'on
couvre on laisse une ou de minutes et
ensuite on fait ce geste où on va remuer
parce que du coup ça va extraire et
faire sortir l'amidon du riz qui va
permettre ce lion avec le fromage et la
matière grasse de donner ce parce que le
riz ne doit pas être trop humide comme
une soupe mais il doit pas être trop
pâteux c'est ça la difficulté du rizuto
et là il est un petit peu craquant quand
même il est un peu légèrement comm al d
voilà d pour les pâtes et et donc voilà
et donc on retrouve ça dans l'assiette
et je dois dire que aujourd'hui vous
l'avez magnifiquement et est-ce que
c'est il y a une recette familiale c'est
votre papa qui le préparait à la maison
oui c'était familial mais c'est c'est
intéressant parce qu'on l'a aussi
enrichi au fil des ans et puis moi je
l'ai recuisiné plus tard moi-même en
famille c'est un des plats que je je
maîtrise j'en maîtrise pas tant que ça
mais quand c'est moi qui suis au
fourneau c'est souvent un risotto à la
milanise où maintenant j'ai j'ai élargi
un petit peu la gamme et je peux faire
des réseotos au citron choses comme ça
mais ah voilà c'est ce que j'allais vous
demander c'est c'est pas que à la
milanaise chez vous il y a aussi non non
ça c'est ça c'est élargé au citron aussi
qui a un super risotto RISOT diviv voilà
ça ça doit dépendre ce que j'allis dire
des saisons en réité r asperg non vous
aspergees avec des petits poid aussi
c'est c'est c'est c'est sans fin en fait
la la famille des des rot alors
j'imagine que vous connaissez bien mais
j'avais quand même Brigit trois petites
astuces pour réussir un risotto
authentique on va voir si Monsieur
Guerini fait un risotto authentique donc
alors on va aller vite il faut surtout
pas de riz basmati mais ça vous le savez
brigitte c'est plutôt un carnaroli ou un
aborio qui sont des riz italien pas
facile à trouver encore que maintenant
même dans les grand surfac voilà alors
si vous le trouvez pas dans votre coin
perdu du Cantal vous vous rabattez sur
un rilon de camarg le bouillon mais il
faut faire un bouillon de poule il faut
bien sûr il y a le geste facile du
bouillon cube mais normalement vous
mettez une poule c'est moins gras qu'un
poulet avec du céleri des carottes des
oignons fa ça prend beaucoup plus de
temps voilà ça c'est 2 à 3 He voilà vous
vous mettez un moi je me suis jamais
lancé làdedansainant il y a des sachets
ce dit pour faire du bouillonou et à la
fin au début du premier geste quand vous
avez mis le riz normalement on on le met
dans un mélange de beurre et d'huile
d'olive mais dans le risoto à la
milanaise on remplace le beurre par une
matière grasse assez insolite qui est de
la moelle de bœuf un eau sal qu'on va
faire blanchir et on va on met cette
moelle dans la casserole et c'est dans
ce mélange d'huile d'olive et de moelle
qu'on va enrober ce ce riz et le nacrer
pour le le faire cuire ensuite dans le
bouillon voilà ça c'est l'Authentic
comment on dit en
italien est-ce
qu'il mais vous parlez magnifiquement
italien je l'ai appris à l'école et
voilà c'est c'est le sens que ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est c'est pas
une transmission directe mais c'est
l'envie de de retrouver des cultures
italiennes et mon frère et moi à l'école
on a appris l'italien et j'ai eu ensuite
l'occasion de de le pratiquer un peu et
c'est vrai qu' quand on s'appelle
Guerini on a envie de parler italien
origines et puis de d'avoir cette double
culture alors il y a le risotto
évidemment mais la cuisine italienne
nous offre des tas de de plats aussi
alléchant les un que les autres il y a
d'autres plats italiens que que vous
cuisinez chez vous
tout type de pâes mais évidemment mais
non non en fait en réalité tout ça c'est
c'est un c'est un grand bordel vous
savez la cuisine tout ça ça se mélange
et et et je dois avouer que j'ai une
épouse qui cuisine magnifiquement bien
et donc voilà on mélange un petit peu
les les pâtes c'est quand même un
incontournable chez les Guerini alors
avec quoi vous vous lesz mélangez
comment vous vous avez desettes pe
familial je vais vous dire moi j'aime
les pâtes les plus simples possibles
j'aime les pâtes avec de l'huile d'olive
et du poivre euh c'est c'est pour moi
les les plus belles alors il faut
prendre des pâtes de qualité il faut les
cuire qualitativement al dente et
ensuite et un petit peu de pécor de
voilà exactement un peu de parmesan râpé
bien sûr et là c'est juste magnifique je
parlais de la cucina povera tout à
l'heure qui est plutôt du sud de
l'Italie alors que vous êtes dans le
Nord un peu plus riche vous aimez cette
cucina poval et je parlais des pâtes au
pois chiches ou des pâtes aux pommes de
terre moi j'adore c'est ouais c'est
délicieux bien sûr bien sûr et j'aime
cette cuisine qui est simple alors c'est
vrai que pour moi ça a du sens aussi
parce que c'est ça permet aussi de de
d'écarner les assiettes de végétaliser
les assiettes et c'est vrai que c'est un
plat qui est végétarien alors qui peut
se manger avec quelques tranches de
jambon italien des S Daniel ou autre et
ça c'est vrai que c'est délicieux il
faut pas se le refuser mais c'est vrai
que c'est aussi un plat qui a du sens
quand on essae bah d'aller vers des
cuisines plus végétales et avec un petit
peu moins de de viande un peu moins de
viande rouge parce que ça joue
évidemment et puis c'est le sens de de
l'histoire et de ce qu'on doit se
retrouver dans nos assiettes aussi
est-ce que vous avez d'autres plat
signatures alors peut-être français
cette fois des plats plus classiques de
la cuisine française ou vous ne savez
pas trop les cuisiner non moi je suis
très très classique donc vous voyez
c'est vraiment quand je vous parlais des
des des pâtes plat de base dans notre
dans notre alimentation c'est c'est
beaucoup ça et vraiment je laisse toute
la la sophistication de cuisine à mon
épouse qui elle cuisine extrêmement
bienime beaucoup quand elle cuisine des
des des plats de hutolengi vous savez
c'est cuisin
extraordinaire ouais exactement
Jérusalem est juste génial et et et qui
permet justement de de faire beaucoup de
cuisine avec beaucoup de légumes avec
des saveurs qu'on qu'on retrouve pas
tout le temps justement dans la cuisine
française doser des choses alors ça va
être des poulets et c'est souvent
extrêmement extrêmement cuit avec
beaucoup d'épices beaucoup de saveur
des plats de pâtes je pense par exemple
un plat de riz avec des des tomates de
la cannelle dedans
desent avec épices effectiv mais bon VO
quand je vous parlais tout à l'heure
d'un peu de parfois de bordelllisation
dans les assiettes bon c'est mieux qu'à
l'Assemblée
non on la retrouve le J nous a pas
influencé ah parce que quand même c'est
Ters voà le foi grve vous le cuisiné ou
alors là vous êtes un peu embêé avec le
FO gr moi j'ai j'ai une grand-mère
bannièraise donc de banère de Big donc
ça c'est toujours du côté paternel donc
cette famille qui est arrivée dans le
gerse à eose qui ensuite a a bougé vers
bannière de bigor elle elle cuisinait du
foie gras cuit avec des gras poilés avec
des grains de raisin po qu'elle préparer
minieusement c'est qu'elle enlevit
justement tous les tous les pépins dans
les grains de raisin pour pouvoir couper
ensuite les raisins en deux les cuire à
la poêle avec de l'armaniaac évidemment
du fois gras poilé ça c'est un PL
absolument magnifique et puis de l'autre
côté familiale du côté de ma maman cette
fois-ci c'était plutôt Sarla pgor noir
et donc là je ne peux pas ne pas vous
parler des plats des pommes de terre
sarladaise avec un magret de canard euh
un plat qui est riche pour le coup en
matière grasse mais mais c'est c'est des
bonne grain dit toujours c'est bon gra
des PL que vous cuisinez
tou quand ça nous arrange c'est des
plats que vous cuisinez toujours
aujourd'hui vous j'avoue que non c'est
les plat qui pour moi étaient réservé au
au aux vacances
au moment chez mes grands-parents c'est
aussi un rapport au temps qui est
différent c'est vrai que aujourd'hui B
on est comme beaucoup de familles
pressées par le boulot avec forcément un
peu moins de temps et cetera et les
pommes de terre sarladis ça prend un peu
plus de temps de préparation il faut
avoir le temps et donc c'est des plats
que je réservais à la cuisine familiale
de vacances son souvenirs a différemment
aujourd'hui peut-être plus léger avec
des moins de viande vous en parliez mais
l'aliment votre alimentation vous direz
à évolué avec les années avec le temps
ouais bien sûr bien sûr euh euh je je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui
maintenant arrive beaucoup plus dans les
habitudes familiales mais je pense que
c'est un sujet qui est
extraordinairement important il y en a
peu au fond qui alignent autant les
intérêts qu'on peut avoir parfois des
intérêts budgétaires de santé et
d'environnement et et on voit que il y a
beaucoup de sujets qui qui créent des
contradictions dans notre société euh ou
et du coup dans les familles aussi et
dans les dans les familles aussi et là
on a la chance avec l'alimentation
d'avoir un sujet qui peut réconcilier
beaucoup d'injonctions qui sont à priori
contradictoires et donc de pouvoir mieux
manger c'estàdire d'avoir du plaisir
dans l'assiette d'intégrer des enjeux de
santé qui sont déterminants et je pense
en disant ça aux jeunes enfants à toutes
les conséquences qui peut y avoir
l'obésité aujourd'hui c'est un problème
que aucun pays au monde n'a réussi à
résoudre et donc par l'alimentation on
peut aligner les les intérêts et et
c'est très difficile de le de de le
faire j'ai discuté le genour avec un un
sociologue qui me parlait de ça en
disant voyez il y a des sujets où il y a
des grandes contradictions euh le tabac
euh c'est un sujet sur lequel il y a eu
des grandes contradictions mais on a
réussi parce que on a changer la la la
culture et aujourd'hui on a cet enjeu
dans l'alimentation là et prendre ce
sujet c'est en cascade résoudre beaucoup
de problèmes de santé des problèmes
budgétaires les conséquences des
dérivees en matière de santé d'obésité
de cancer et cetera sur système de santé
elles sont énormes mais aussi pour des
sujets je dirais de la vie quotidienne
voyez le le le rapport que ce ce
sociologue là faisait l'autre jour c'est
de me dire voyez les problèmes de
harcèlement à l'école par exemple c'est
très souvent lié à des sujets d'obésité
chez les enfants des
enfants qui ont des problèmes de
surpoids qui sont obèses vous faites une
sortie scolaire mais vous voyez c'est
des enfants qui sont souvent isolés et
qui sont souvent entre eux moi ça m'a
sauté au visage quand il m'a dit des
choses comme ça et et et on voit que le
rapport de ce qui se passe dans nos
assiettes avec des enjeux de société
comme celui par exemple du harcellement
à l'école qui est aujourd'hui centrale
et qui doit être une mobilisation
nationale qui l' d'ailleurs
l'alimentation peut avoir un rôle aussi
on voit les les conséquences donc je
pense que ça doit changer la vie des
français des familles ça doit aussi
changer dans la la restauration
collective moi je me sens évidemment une
responsabilité très forte voyez vous
prenez la la la restauration dans l'état
c'est 4 100 millions de repas chaque
année c'est c'est c'est énormeou PZ
changer les choses c'est un vrai levier
oua voilà changer les choses et parfois
parce que on va apprendre des choses au
travail dans la restauration collective
B on va emmener un peu tout ça chez soi
et peut-être mieux manger et réussir à
réaligner les intérêts et vraiment
encore une fois c de la santé du
portefeuille de l'environnement ils sont
complètement alignés en vous parlez
effectivement beaucoup de la santé c'est
vrai que c'est très ce qu'on mange est
évidemment déterminant vous vous faites
très attention à ce que vous achetez euh
vous regardez bien les étiquettes ou
est-ce que vous achetez euh précisément
du bio parce que vous dites il faut pas
de pesticides ça peut être dangereux
je pense que je suis un peu comme tous
les Français c'estàdire que on on est
sans cesse voilà dans des dans des
contradictions euh euh on essaie de bien
faire bah voilà je pense que le le le
fait de de se poser la question aussi de
ce qu'on donne à ses enfants évidemment
ça change toujours complètement la donne
donc il y a une attention peut-être plus
forte euh qu'on peut avoir sur les
enfants et euh les contradictions euh
voilà de continuer à grignoter quand il
faudait pas
grignoter à se laisser aller à quelques
gourmandises des trucs où il y a des
dedans des es juvant des machins tous
les mauvais trucs je pense que personne
peut dire qu'il a une alimentation parfa
il y a pas des aliments que vous avez
banis par exemple de la maison en vous
disant non là vraiment j'ai regardé
c'est c'est vraiment maais la santé n
c'est c'est manger moins de viande rouge
voilà mais pour moi c'était plutôt une
considération environnementale même
qu'une considération santé initialement
alors rité c'est les deux de c'est deux
mais quand quand on voit
euh j'ai l'occasion de de de de faire
des atelier travail là-dessus
d'embarquer un petit peu aussi dans
l'administration on a fait tout mon
cabinet un atelier qui s'appelle
l'atelier 2 tonnes au sens de 2 tonnes
de CO2 donc ça c'est l'objectif qu'on
doit se fixer aujourd'hui on est plutôt
à 9 10 tonnes par français mais vous
voyez sur ces 9 tonnes il y en a 2,5 qui
sont liés à l'alimentation et donc on
voit bien qu'on a un enjeu là-dessus
mais que on doit pas prendre les choses
en faisant des leçons de morale aux gens
et surtout quand il y a des difficultés
de fin de mois des difficultés à boucler
le le le panier mais qu'on doit donner
les bonnes informations on doit montrer
que on peut réconcilier ces sujetsl
aussi avec des sujets de plaisir dans
l'assiette je pense que c'est très
important de d'embarquer B voilà par la
pédagogie et aussi en retrouvant une
notion de plaisir et ce qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui autour de parler
effectivement après aussi en deux mots
pour rebondir ce que vous disiez à
partir pour pour la santé vous parliez
du temps tout à l'heure est-ce que sur
l'Hôtel du temps vous êtes être prêt à
sacrifier de de la bonne alimentation en
achetant des produits transformés ou du
surgelé en quelques mot
ouais vous voyez aujourd'hui moi ça ça
fait partie de mes arbitrages les plus
difficiles euh parce que je vais pas
vous faire
croire passayant là que bah justement du
temps j'en ai beaucoup et donc c'est
vrai qu'on va souvent vite ce que je
constate c'est que c'est pas forcément
beaucoup plus long de cuisiner bien et à
partir de matière non transformé donc je
vais pas faire croire que je passe 3
heur de plus à cuisiner mais je pense
qu'on peut bien faire en faisant des
choses plutôt simples justement qui
permettent de réconcilier un petit peu
tout ça donc vous évitez un peu ces
produits transformés trop gr trop
sucrésou oui je pense que j'en mange
moins que en tout cas il y a 10 ans
quand dans les débuts de ma vie
professionnelle j'allais au supermarché
à côté je mangais à peu près que des
plats cuisinés ce qui avait le ouais
c'est bon non pas pour un Italien oh non
non su j'en ai mangé beaucoup hein il y
a pas de problème là-dessus alors on va
déguster ce vin avec avec ce ris AUO à
la milanaise c'est un un médoc que vous
avez souhaitz partager avec nous donc
c'est un des grands vins de Bordeaux
évidemment on est à l'entrée de
l'Estoire de la Gironde au-dessus de
saint-estf de de Poyac de Saint-Julien
de margaot des très belles appellations
c'est un aocé évidemment euh les cpages
on est dans du Cabernet sauignon Merlot
petit mer petit ver d'eau et Malbec
c'est un millésim 2017 et ça
particularité il a des arômes de fruits
rouges noirs et du café torrifié est-ce
que vous reconnaissez le mdoc que vous
aimez alors moi je suis pas du tout un
nologue et et et un grand spécialiste
donc là je je bois vos paroles d'abord
avant de le goûter
he et peut dire fruit rou déjà sans
vouloir rendre jaloux ceux qui nous
regardent que il est extrêmement bon et
très agréable et je trouve que ça marche
très bien avec un
réoto moi c'est c'est un vin qui me qui
me parle parce que c'est là aussi des
racines familiales le Médoc c'est
castelne pour moi et c'est une part des
origines des origines de de ma famille
côté maternel cette fois-ci c'est un vin
qui est enraciné dans une histoire
familiale et je trouve que voilà ça
égille un un repas et je retrouve tout
ce que vous avez dit dedans vous l'avez
infiniment mieux commenté que moi le vin
c'est une histoire de famille aussi je
crois chez chez les
Guerini oui mais mais de tout simplement
de ceux qui aiment passer à table et et
c'est vrai que ça va et on est français
avec avec un un un beau repas ouais
c'est une histoire aussi de famille il
s'avère que ça remonte très très loin
mais je crois même que ma famille a été
liée à un domaine viticol s'appelle le
château lagurg voyez dans le dans le
Médoc et que ça n'est plus tout le cas
aujourd'hui mais ce sont des attaches
qui qui sont très profondément dans les
terres du Médoc j'ai une question pour
Brigit qui est la spécialiste du vin don
quand on a un risoto comme ça ou un plat
avec des épices le safran c'est assez
fort qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre plutôt
du rouge ou plutôt du blanc pour pour
faire exister ce C Y a un paradoxe parce
que il y a il y a laaccord des couleurs
qui marche à tous les coups qui est
censé accorder en fait la couleur du vin
avec la couleur du plat et et ça marche
assez bien c'estàd qu'avec par exemple
un poulet il vaut mieux prendre du du
vin blanc mais là comme il y a du safran
et que c'est assez relevé je trouve que
le laaccore se marie très très bien avec
un vin rouge qui est quand même assez
assez puissant donc je trouve que c'est
c'est un accord réussi bon ben tant
mieux et en plus il est à votre goût
j'ai toujours été marqué par un truc
avec le vin c'est presque aussi la façon
dont on en parle et l'instant qu'on
prend autour à partager bien sûr c'est
c'est c'est moi je m'estime pas du tout
spécialiste et et on peut avoir un goût
qui varie aussi avec la psychologie qui
qui va autour quand on vous parle bien
d'un vin quand on vous décrit l'accord
avec les aliments
tout change quoi et c'est ça aussi la
magie je crois des mots qu'on peut
mettre autour des sensations des
sensations culinaires et je trouve que
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire avec le
vin parce que on aime entendre parler du
vin vous en parlez très bien en
l'occurrence et donc ça rend le moment
aussi agréable ETP alors on va voir si
vous êtes vraiment incollable en c'est
le
quiz alors on l'a vu un du sang italien
coule dans vos veines Stanislas Guerini
ce qui fait naturellement de vous un
amateur de parmesan le roi des fromages
de la botte dites-nous si ces
affirmations le concernant
là vous allez être déçu là c'est au 12e
siècle que les moines de PARM ont
commencé à produire ce fromage à pâte
dur oui mais ça évidemment c'est c'est
c'est vrai non j'en ai d'abord aucune
idée mais vu comment la question est
formulée je suis sûr que c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai regard
beaucoup je télévis alors une seule race
bovine la frisona italiana produit le
lait pour le parmesan ah ça c'est la
deuxème question ah oui mais non bien
sûr ça serait évidemment infiniment
réducteur que de penser ça exactement il
y a quatre races bovines d'où vous
l'avez dit la richesse de ce fromage
mais ce que vous avez pas compris c'est
que je suis très fort en jeu télévisé
parce que j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
dans ma vie à regarder la télévision et
donc alors pour l'instant de sur
de il existe des Parmesans affinés 140
mois oui bien sûr ils sont même très
connus donc c'est les fameux 140 Mo
alors alors je il a raison mais je mets
juste je mets juste un bémol c'est que
c'est pas très connu parce que c'est
exceptionnel et ça doit être très rare
mais ça existe et à mon avis ça doit
être le max parce que super commence à
faire beaucou je précise que les
questions n'ont pas été données avant et
alors attention la meilleure façon de
conserver un bon parmesan chez vous
c'est de le
congeler ça euh je pense que c'est faux
mais c'est faux et oui c'est surtout pas
le congé bien s surtout italien
maintenant on en est sûr alorsendez on
va essayer quand même de le piéger parce
qu'il y a un deuxième quiz vous avez
donc été au Lycée Henri VI un roi
gourmet sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations à son sujet sont vrais a il
adorait l'ail et l'oignon aux grand
d'âes de ses favorites ah ça c'est ça
doit être bien vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai son vin préféré est le côte de nuit
non bien sûr que non c'est vrai
de
giverie il avait mais le truc c'est de
mettre beaucoup
d'assuranceou là vous êtes bon il avait
son rond de serviette à la Tour d'Argent
oui qui a un restaurant qui existait
déjà à l'époque non mais c'est vrai en
plus il détestait les il adorait le pâté
de Héron sans doute à le Tour d'Argent
j'ai mal mal connu en fait le roi H 4
mais sans doute il détestait les huîtres
à tel point que la consigne était de ne
jamais en servir à sa table ah les
dernières questions sont s plusieurs
dans le dans le
quiz et ça je pense que c'est vrai aussi
alors non c'est faux ah là là il ador
les hres il adorait les
huitres c'est quand même un très très
bon MIM pour vous alors vous savez que
c'est souvent à table que ce nous les
meilleures histoires qui a qui a parfois
des deals politiques et c'est la brve de
comptoir alors Stanislas Guerini on vous
a demandé de réfléchir à une anecdote
politique autour d'un repas est-ce qu'il
y a une histoire qui vous est revenue à
l'esprit ben moi comme vous m'avez posé
cette question en fait le truc qui m'est
tout de suite venu à l'esprit c'est les
repas militant parce que tout bon
responsable politique sait que pour
avoir du monde à une réunion politique
il faut inviter à manger et qui a un
coup à boire et c'est ça qui fait les
plus beaux moments et les plus belles
réunions politiques je crois que tous
les maires savent ça quand ils font un
grand repas une fois par an avec un
grand banquet là ça fonctionne là où il
y a beaucoup de monde donc évidemment
est-ce qu'on est sûr d'avoir les voix
derrière c'est pas sûr ça c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça et je
m'aventurerai même pas là-dedans mais au
moins on est sûr qu'il y aura du monde
qu'on va pouvoir passer un bon moment et
au fond moi c'est ça qui m'a comme vous
m'aveit dit c'est quoi la bref de
comptoir autour de la nourriture j'ai
pensé à tous ces moments militants voilà
moi j'ai été chef de parti pendant 3 ans
et demi j'étéis à la tête d'en marche et
c'est pas toujours facile quand on se
prend pas tout le temps des victoire
électorale il y a plein plein d'emmerd
quand on est à la tête d'un d'un parti
politique mais il y a aussi plein
moments qui sont des moments magnifiques
voilà il y a quelques jours on était
réunis pour le campus de renaissance à
Bordeaux bord ben moi j'ai organisé les
les les premiers campus c'était à
Bordeaux il y a maintenant un peu plus
de 4 ans et c'était toujours des moments
absolument incroyable qui réunissait qui
réunissaiit autour aussi de moments
militants le soir autour de banquet de
nourriture c'est des moments en fait où
il se passent des trucs dans votre vie
que vous auriez jamais imaginé avant il
y a il y a il y a 4 ans à Bordeaux on
avait invité le chef Raoni qui défend la
la forêt amazonienne et qui est venu
avec petite délégation comme ça et puis
on était là assis autour d'un d'un plat
on partageait un moment et c'était
extraordinaire de pouvoir parler avec le
chefette photo à l'écran vous pouvez pet
la commenterà bah voilà ça c'est un
moment qui est pour moi
extrêmement extrêmement émouvant en
réalité parce que il parle de des causes
des des des de ses combats et c'est un
moment qui est hyper humain voilà où il
se c'est un moment de de de partage euh
et c'est vrai que la la le le fait de
partager un moment aussi autour d'un
banquet et cetera ça ça permet ça et
alors là pour la petite histoire vous
avez mangé avec lui ou pas après on a
mangé un bout et et ce qui est quand
même étonnant et et marrant c'est que on
parle des sujets les plus importants
peut-être en soi la forêt amazonienne le
le le poumon de de l'humanité et puis il
avait un traducteur donc tout ça pr beau
beauoup parle un dialect amazonien B
ouais ouais voilà moi je comprenais rien
évidemment j'attendais j'attendais à
chaque fois donc c'est c'est puis puis
il se passe des trucs dans les yeux et
cetera que vous avait des traductions
comme ça en attendant de comprendre et
puis au bout d'un moment j'ai compris
que le chef Raoni avait aussi des
besoins naturels et donc ça faisait une
demi-heure qu'on était ensemble et au
bout d'un moment de 5 minutes de
traduction il dit le chef Raoni vraiment
doit maintenant vous quitter parce que
il a envie d'aller aux toilettes et donc
là tout le monde s'est marré autour de
la table et donc le chef Raoni a pu
aller aux toilettes et ce sont aussi des
moments de vraie vie comme ça qu'on vit
partage sur et le partage alors on va on
va cuisiner et on va consommer de façon
plus vertueuse ça c'est vrai beaucoup
s'y mettent mais comment s'y prend-on et
qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve dans l'assiette
c'est le dessous des
plats dans votre ministère vous montrez
l'exemple avec de nouvelles pratiques
plus respectueuses de l'environnement on
le voit dans l'assiette mais pas
seulement une consommation responsable
qui s'impose plus largement dans la
fonction public Hélène Bonduel et Pierre
dein sont invités dans vos cuisines
allez bon courage bonne journée à vous
merci au revoir 9h arrivé des dernières
livraisons alors aujourd'hui on a reçu
des escalopes on va faire des escalopes
milanaises cette semaine
allez-y cette semaine mais pas
aujourd'hui ce midi ni viande ni poisson
au menu du ministre et des 80
collaborateur de la secrétaire au
conseiller le plus proche donc
aujourd'hui nous avons une gravio de
légumes avec une tendance un peu
asiatique avec un bouillon miso qui
viendra accompagner tout ça dedans vous
avez du chitakeet de la
carotte du céleris du poireau on essaie
de garder des produit de saison et en
plat un parmentier de
légumes donc là je fais une tuile de
pommes de terre un petit peu d'huile de
noisette c'est la
saison
voilà depuis 2 ans deux fois par semaine
les menus du ministère sont entièrement
végétariens une cuisine plus vertueuse
plus respectueuse de l'environnement
mais pas seu je vais être honnête avec
vous il y a aussi les coûts des matières
premières qui accéléré le fait qu'on
consomme un peu plus de
légumes parce que tout a pris des des
prix de plus de 10 12 % au niveau de la
viande et le poisson je vous en parle
pas voilà donc du coup les légumes
restent encore des produits abordables
derrière les fourneaux l'équipe a dû
s'adapter redoubler
d'inventivité le but c'est quand même
qu' à manger donc des fois avec les
légumes on peut avoir tendance à donner
un petit peu moins mais avec des légumes
comme les légumineuses les féculant on
arrive tout à fait à à leur proposer des
repas complets diversifiés on a la
chance d'avoir en retour des ministres
et des conseillers qui sont contents
d'avoir on a même des conseillers qui
moi j'aime pas ça mais j'ai goûté et du
coup j'ai trouvé
çaana on va aller le compost tu
viens les habitudes de travail aussi ont
changé plus question de jeter les
épluchures pas mal aujourd'hui pas mal
de tout le choule éta fait les panets
elles sont désormais valorisé et ça se
passe dans le compost au fond des
jardins
c'est avec les jardiniers de Matignon du
coup on valorise le produit de A à Z ce
compost va servir à
fertiliser le petit coin de légumes
qu'on a de de d'Herb aromatique là j'ai
mets des feuilles pour fa pas que ça
soit cesse c'est les feill Mor quand
c'est fini les J il vont remettre en
place voilà tiens
regarde ça on va en prendre un petit peu
ministère de la Fonction publique est un
précurseur mais d'ici quelques mois les
2500 cuisiniers d'État seront formés aux
enjeux d'une alimentation plus
sobre alors Stanislas Guerini pourquoi
avoir imposé deux menus végétarien par
semaine dans votre ministère bah d'abord
vous voyez que ça ça suscite pas
beaucoup de de de difficultés parfois
c'est un peu des cass-etêes et cetera
mais mais moi j'ai beaucoup de fierté en
fait en regardant le le reportage qu'on
qu'on vient de voir en voyant le notre
chef Marc qui est bon on voit à l'image
un chef exceptionnel et et pourquoi on a
fait ça ben parce que tout simplement
euh les moments qu'on vit ce quinquena
doit être celui du changement d'échelle
du passage à l'échelle et de la
planification écologique et et moi je
considère que ça doit se faire dans tous
les champs de politique publique mais
aujourd'hui la loi c'est un seul menu
végétarien en tout cas dans les cantines
ou pour vous avez souhaité aller plus
loin mais en l'occurrence je pense que
quand on est la fonction publique on a à
la fois une responsabilité pour
nous-mêmes l'impact tout à l'heure je
vous disais il y a 400 millions de repas
qui sont servis dans l'état chaque année
donc c'est c'est c'est considérable et
et on peut décliner ça sur toutes les
dimensions sur l'énergie sur l'eau et
cetera c'est c'est un impact
extraordinairement fort mais on a aussi
une force d'entraînement pour le reste
de la société parce que les gens nous
disent bah vous êtes bien sympa parfois
de nous demander de faire ça ou ça de
faire des efforts de soriété et cetera
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites vous et
etemple ça ouais bien sûr que ce que
j'ai vu à chaque fois c'est que quand on
a commencé par nous-même l'État en fait
on a été crédible pour ensuite demander
des choses ça ça s'est passé exactement
comme ça pour la sobriété énergétique
vous souvenez c'était un an on a lancé
ce ce ce grand plan on a dit il faut
qu'on arrive à à réduire de de 10 % nos
efforts et l'État on s'est engagé très
fortement on l'a fait en 6 mois et et je
pense que ça rend crédible ensuite pour
pouvoir demander des choses donc ça veut
dire que toute la fonction publique va
se mettre à ce rythme là ouais on va
former c'était dit dans votre dans votre
reportage mais dans le cadre de la
planification écologique exactement et
c'est très très important en réalité de
pouvoir accompagner moi ce à quoi je
crois pas du tout et de moins en moins
je vais vous dire d'autant plus en étant
en étant ministre maintenant c'est un
peu l'effet circulaire quoi voyez on
écrit dans une belle circulaire
ministérielle voilà les engagements le
truc
verticalout ouais surtout faut que ce
soit crédiible et que ça se fasse pas
sur le dos ni des administrations ni des
agents et et souvent je je remarquais
que c'était perçu comme ça c'est qu'on
donnait des règles qui faisaent très
bien sur le papier et puis ensuite on
disait bon surtout espérons que dans 3
ans les trucs soient fait et puis c'est
un peu fait ce que je dis mais pas que
je fais qus étaient les moyens pour
accompagner comment on rendit les choses
crédibles le le rôle d'un gouvernement
c'est pas de faire des leçons de morale
euh c'est de fixer de la norme
évidemment mais c'est de mettre les
citoyens en capacité de pouvoir faire et
ça c'est vrai aussi dans les
administration vous êtes sûr que ça
entraî derrière les citoyens j'en suis
absolument convaincu la règle seule elle
ne suffit pas la contrainte on voit bien
qu'on est plein d'injonctions
contradictoirees on on on en parlait ça
ne suffit pas il faut se donner les
moyens de réussir et donc ce que
j'essaie de faire euh à ma modeste
échelle qui est celle de l'État qui est
celle de la fonction publique c'est
d'accompagner de donner les outils et je
crois que cet exemple là de la formation
des cuisiniers parfois moi j'ai j'ai
même noté que ça faisait sourire
certains en disant ben ouais en fait on
va mettre de l'argent pour pouvoir
former mais alors vous les former
comment par que juste retirer la viande
c'est facile ça va être des des
formations qui sont très approfondies
aux achats vous voyez qu'il y avait des
des des enjeux sur les achats à la
décarbonation des assiettes les jeunes
ont déjà cette conscience en qui a
changé un peu par rapport à l'ancienne
génération côté générationnel et en fait
surtout j'ai l'impression que tout le
monde a envie euh et et là les jeunes
comme les anciens et cetera quand on s'y
met c'est c'est un effet d'entraînement
quoi en réalité et donc c'est c'est pas
si simple que ça parce que ça veut dire
que il faut aller chercher des
diversités de produits de légumes de
penser les saisons il y a des légumes
qui sont plus résistants qui vont nous
permettre de penser cette siété
d'adaptation aussi face au changement
climatique apprendre à consommer
différemment ouais et et la réalité
c'est que c'est très fin ça se décrète
pas comme ça si du jour au lendemain
vous dites à tout le monde je vous
impose de retirer tel ou tel aliment et
cetera là vous allez être dans la
contrainte mais si vous apporte des
solutions et vous dites regardez comment
on peut faire différemment regardez
comment et je crois que ça se voyait à
l'image on peut faire des plats qui sont
magnifiques et en même temps qui
correspondent à ce qu'on a besoin de
faire ben là ça change tout quoi vous
dites ça se passe bien regardz les
cuisiniers bien les cuisiniers il aime
bien cuisiner les légumes pas de viande
ça les embête pas forcément mais moi
j'attends la réaction des agents il y a
pas eu des résistances au début il y a
pas eu
des crouis si bien sûr bien sûr que je
vous raconterai les histoires en disant
qu est-ce qu'on va avoir assez dans les
assiettes moi j'ai besoin de mes
calories et C mes protéines bon et et en
fait rapidement voilà maintenant c'est
un débat
qui m diap je peux vous le garantir et
je vous jure que je fais pas semblant
comme pendant le quiz tout à l'heure de
connaître les réponses c'est pas la
langue de bois euh aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est que plus personne dans les
l'équipe là la la petite PME qu'on qu'on
constitue remet en cause ce qu'il y a
dans les assiettes et c'est un plaisir
pour tout le monde c'est ce que je
disais sur la la nourriture c'est un des
rares sujets où on peut aligner tous les
intérêts et et et il y en a peu en fait
comme ça et et c'est intéressant parce
que d'ailleurs le le le chef le disait
les prix ont augmenté l'inflation
alimentaire ça permet de réduire aussi
le coût de l'alimentation bien sûr et on
peut faire
différemment je pense que on a là un
très très très beau sujet de consommer
de produits bio qui sont plus chers
aussi que parfois des produits locaux B
c'est c'est c'est justement ça va
permettre de faire basculer euh le fait
de mettre du budget par exemple dans de
la viande en se disant bah on va acheter
des produits qui coûtent un peu plus
cher parce que il faut pouvoir rémunérer
ce qu'il le font mais
aussiouvir ouvrir un marché parce que
c'est ça l'intérêt euh c'est pas que de
l'exemplarité c'est quand on prend la
restauration collective qu'elle soit
dans le privé qu'elle soit dans le
public ça permet de faire basculer et
d'ouvrir un marché pour démocratiser
justement la nourriture bi oui mais al
vous ouvrez le marché du bio mais
qu'est-ce que vous dites aux éleveur
parce que eux ils ont effectivement leur
bête ils ont un manque à gagner qui est
important par que ça per de pouvoir
privilégier la récompense de la qualité
de pouvoir là où on va économiser parce
que on va un peu décarboner l'assiette
la végétaliser on va pouvoir consacrer
un petit peu plus de budget à acheter de
la viande de bonne qualité et
récompenser les filières et la filière
d'élevage française est une filière
d'excellence qui doit être rémunérée
pour le travail qu'elle mène et pour
l'excellence qu'elle mène et donc ça va
permettre d'acheter un peu plus circuit
court d'acheter plus français d'acheter
plus bio éventuellement et et c'est
comme ça qu'on va réconcilier ces
injonctions contradictoires et le le on
doit nous gouver essayer de de défaire
les nœuds et de trouver des solutions
question un petit peu provoque pour
finir en Suède les ministres ils mangent
dans des cantines avec des tickets
restaurants là quand on voit les
cuisines du ministère on se dit ça
ressemble à un grand restaurant est-ce
que c'est encore dans l'air du temps
est-ce que c'est le modèle français
est-ce qu'on peut au moment où on doit
faire des économie sur sur le dos de
l'État continuer à entretenir des par en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence on on on le
fait et il y a des contraintes
budgétaires qui sont assez fortes là les
chefs et la la brigade elle travaille
pour 80 personnes qui travaille pour
deux ministres en l'occurrence dans les
les bâtiments dans lesquels on est une
petite équipe donc je pense que c'est
pas démesuré mais c'est aussi c'est vrai
une chance immense de pouvoir accéder
tous les jours à une nourriture de
grande qualité avec cette attention là
qui est portée mais mais c'est pour moi
vraiment l'occasion de de de valoriser
le travail d'agents public qui sont
extraordinairement engagés qui font des
choses qui ont du sens et et on donne du
sens au contraire à leur boulot en se
disant bah à travers ce que vous faites
pour nos assiettes peut-être que on va
irriguer accompagner former sensibiliser
aussi des gens qui ont des levier de
décision entre leurs mains qui sont très
importantes vous savez moi peut-être un
des projets les plus importants que j'ai
lancé depuis que je suis ministre c'est
la formation de 25000 cadres de
l'administration d'État à la transition
écologique alors on y parle alimentation
on y parle CO2 on y parle biodiversité
vous l'avez vu à travers les espaces
verts on y parle crise des ressources et
ce projet là qui est pas une Pete
formation une visio et puis c'est fini
hein c'est 3 jours de formation pour
tous ceux qui ont les leviers entre
leurs mains de décision les plus
importants les préfets les directrices
directeurs d'administration centrale nos
ambassadeurs bref toute la haute
fonction publique et est formée et les
retours qu'on a de ce projet ils sont
extraordinaires je le dis vraiment comme
je le pense parce que non seulement on
est en train de changer des choses sur
le les enjeux environnementaux mais on
la façon de manager de penser l'action
publique et ça c'est une opportunité qui
est extraordinaire ben parce qu'on voit
qu'on a beaucoup de choses à remettre à
plat aujourd'hui dans la façon de
conduire les les politiques publiques
donc de l'assiette jusque au politiqu
publi ouais on peut pe changer alors
vous nous parlez d'environnement on va
continuer à en parler puisque 2023
devrait être l'année la plus chaude
jamais connue sur cette terre un
réchauffement et un dérèglement qui nous
plonge dans une pénurie d'eau
indispensable à la vie sur Terre on en
parle et on met les pieds dans le plat
oui Brigitte montrée des épisodes de
sécheresse de plus en plus fréquents en
France les expérimentations sur
l'utilisation des eaux usées dans
l'agriculture se multiplie il faut dire
que la France accuse un sacré retard sur
d'autres pays alors un exemple
d'expérimentation sur l'île de porcorol
dans leev c'est un reportage de nos
confrères de France 3
PACA 100000 m cubes d'eau sont
nécessaires chaque année pour les
besoins des habitants de porqueeroll
dans cette station dépuration une fois
traité les EAU usées sont ensuite
déversées dans des lagunes les rayons UV
du soleil font le reste cette eau au
lieu d'être rejetée dans le milieu tel
quelle dans le milieu naturel
c'est-à-dire à la mer elle est rejetée
dans les lagune ce qui permet de de dans
un traitement biologique sans aucun
apport de produit chimique de faire un
dernier traitement tercière qui permet
la réutilisation dans l'irrigation
agricole 17 ha s de végétation sont
irrigué mais ces eau n'étant pas propre
à la consommation la réglementation
interdit l'aspersion le goutte à goutte
est donc l'unique option cette eau
permet l'irrigation effectivement de
parcelles alors soit de fruits issus de
l'arborculture qui touche pas le sol ou
alors des fruits qui touchent le sol
mais qui seront thermoransformés hein
des confitures ou des soupes por est un
exemple à suivre dans le sens où ça fait
40 ans que ces installations sont là
elles ont démontrer leur efficacité
l'île varoise économiserait ainsi
jusqu'à 10 % de sa consommation mais
pour ce militant de la protection de
l'environnement encourager davantage
cette pratique présente un risque
sanitaire évident il préconise plutôt de
changer nos habitude vous avez toujours
le risque qu'il reste des bactéries des
virus des parasites des produits
chimiques réduisons notre consommation
au besoins essentiels et ensuite
peut-être voir comment on peut
réutiliser mieux réutiliser l'auous
traité France Nature Environnement
craint aussi que ces eau réutilisées ne
favorisent une agriculture intensive
dans une ire où l'eau est devenu plus
que jamais un bien très précieux alors
ce sont 1 % monsieur Grini des EAU usées
qui sont réutilisé à des fins agricoles
en France contre 90 % en Israël 14 % en
Espagne 60 % à Malte 1% 8 % en Italie
pourquoi comment expliquer un tel retard
alors je suis pas moi un spécialiste
d'agriculture mais parce que on a des
normes et une parfois une complexité
administrative qui empêchait la
réutilisation des eau et on voit à quel
point c'est un enjeu aujourd'hui et je
trouve ça très intéressant parce qu'il a
les France Nature Environnement qui
d'ailleurs nous accompagne beaucoup dans
nos projets de de formation et qui
montrait que on doit à mon sens pas
opposer la sobriété des usages donc on
doit d'abord diminuer notre consommation
en eau on pourra y revenir parce que
quand si l'état s met là aussi ça va
avoir de l'impact et mieux réutiliser
les les EAU moi je je je je constate que
il y a des acteurs dans l'agriculture
des acteurs industriels qui étaient
complètement empêché de pouvoir
réutiliser leur propre eau dans leur
propre process par les ARS notamment qui
étaient très pointilux sur
appliqu appliquaient la loi elles
appliquaient les normes qu'on se donnait
mais elle faisait qu'on avait pris un
retard incroyable tout simplement qu'on
consommait l'eau parce qu'on en avait
beaucoup à la
différence pour ça je pense qu'il faut
pas opposer les de en fait on faisait
pas attention on a besoin de faire les
deux à la fois maintenant on a besoin
d'être beaucoup plus sobre dans nos
usages et de beaucoup plus réutilisé je
vais vous donner un exemple très concret
euh depuis 2 ans on a mis en place un
dispositifp qui s'appelle France
expérimentation ça permet d'accompagner
des acteurs des PME des boîtes qui ont
des projets innovants et qui se trouvent
empêchés par la complexité
administrative le droit existant et donc
on a accompagné en l'occurrence Volvic
Danon des usines pour vérifier avec eux
et les suivre dans leur meilleure
réutilisation de leur propre auous donc
c'est un peu la même chose que ce qu'on
dans le reportage il nettoie déjà trois
fois l'eau un circuit interne en fait et
cette eau là il ne pouvait pas la
réutiliser pour nettoyer leur propre
cuve industriel je suis allé avec mes
collèguesés le BO on est allit voir de
nos yeux et non mais il nous disait que
c'était absurde l'eau vous l'auriez bu
elle était ah elle était consommable
elle était était attention entre une eau
propre et une eau potable il y a différ
ou ouais bien sûr mais ce que je dire
c'est qu'elle était trois fois filtrée
elle était remise à un niveau et c'était
de l'eau issu de leur
h et la rglation les empêch de
réutiliser cet e pour nettoyer leur
propre cuve industrielle c'est absurde
c'est se taper la tê m atttion aux
baéries attention au risque
San en accompagnant et donc évidemment
on a eu un suivi encore plus particulier
des retours de ce que ça pouvait donner
on l'a suivi avec les autorités de santé
c'est pour ça qu'on y allit à plusieurs
ministres environnement fonction
publique pour simplifier et santé et on
s'est rendu compte que il y avait aucune
difficulté en matière de santé et les
deux projets dont je suis en train de
vous parler c'est 600 millions de mètres
cbes tous les ans qu'on va pouvoir
sauver parce qu'on va les réutiliser
alors que ils
étit dans l'riculture là en l'occurrence
c'est dans un dans un un process
industriel industriel pour nettoyer des
machines pour nettoyer des cules
l'acheter elle sert à quelque chose
exactement mais vous avez un objectif
aussi dans la fonction publque
révolution de baisser de 10 %
bien si on réduit dans la fonction
publique juste pour l'état de 10% notre
consommation d'eau c'est comme si toute
la ville d'angoulem s'arrêtait pendant
un an de consommer de l'eau donc vous
voyez l'impact qu'on peut avoir mais ça
c'est à quelle échéance qu'on peut
réduire de 10% moi ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'on le fasse d'ici un an d'ici
un an donc ça veut dire qu'on on
gaspille de l'eau aujourd'hui ouais
ouais ben c'est
pascoup les f je crois c'est beaucoup
mais la réalité c'est que c'est faisable
et que c'est faisable c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire avec le sujet de l'eau
sans impacter notre qualité de vie au
quotidien c'est faisable avec des trucs
où parfois on se dit mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a pas fait ça avant en
mettant des mousseurs sur les robinets
ça change tout vous l'avez pas moins
bien les mains parce que vous avez un
mousseur sur le robinet en mettant des
dispositifs dans les chasses d'eau
pardon d'aborder ce type de sujet qui
sont un peu terre à terre mais voyez une
chasse d'eau si je dis pas de bêtis je
crois que c'est 9 l d'eau potable donc
vous vous imaginez en train de verser
des bouteilles d'eau potable pour
l'usage de la chasse d'eau on a des
dispositifs qu'on va mettre tout
bêtement dans les chasses d'eau qui
permettent de gagner 1 L et demi à
chaque fois qu'on tire la chasse voyez
l'impact que ça va et ne me faites pas
croire que ça un impact sur la qualité
de vie au quotidien des fonctionnaires
qui utiliseront ça on on peut y arriver
et donc il faut qu'on ait des
démonstrateurs pour montrer que les
choses sont faisables qu'on peut bouger
on a fait 10 % d'économie sur
l'électricité et le gaz là en 6 mois et
on va le faire sur l'eau et je crois que
c'est une extraordinaire force
d'entraînement pour la société française
de dire on peut réussir et je vais vous
dire une chose c'est que plus on le fait
plus on va le faire et que il y a cet
effet aussi d'entraînement où on se dit
c'est possible ça donne du sens au
travail et et moi je crois que ça fait
longtemps qu'on n pas eu une opportunité
aussi extraordinaire que la transition
écologique pour donner du sens au
travail des agents publics moi j'ai j'ai
mis des sujet sur la table je parle
parfois de rémunération au mérite et je
sais que parfois ça ça peut tendre quand
on entend ça mais si on se disait que
dans les objectifs qu'on se fixe tiens
qui pourrait être des objectifs pour un
plan d'intéressement pour les
fonctionnaires par exemple on mettrait
les questions de réussite d'atteinte de
nos plan de sobriété en matière
d'énergie en matière d'eau mais ça
aurait beaucoup de sens c'est des choses
qui sont parfaitement mesurables qui
mobilisent des équipes vous voulez faire
ouais ça fait partie des projets que je
porte et c'est pas un sujet tabou pour
moi parce que la réalité c'est que que
la fonction publique elle doit relever
aujourd'hui des grands défis qui
s'appelle la transition écologique qui
s'appelle la transition démographique
s'appelle la transition numérique et que
ces grands défis là ils doivent nous
conduire à repenser la façon dont on
travaille dont on objective les choses
dont on mobilise les agents et ça donne
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de sens et je
crois que Ben mettre des enjeux de
rémunération en face de ça ouais c'est
pas tabou bon tout le monde a fini on va
passer au dessert et c'est le pécher
mignon alors c'est le temps du sucré
hein Brigitte avec des fruits de saison
c'est ce que vous avez choisi c'est un
Islas guini mais pas n'importe lesquels
fruits hein chez Françoise nous a
préparé une cette salade de poire très
bien très bien organisé et pas
d'incident en vue Stanislas guini parce
qu'on m'a dit que vous ne supportez pas
tous les fruits ah ouais c'est
vrai c'est bête comme ch mais mais mais
j'ai des allergies voilà comme plein g
fruit avec tous les fruits à peau voyez
donc non oui pardon c'est vrai là j'ai
vraiment l'air bête mais mais des fruits
type les les fruits avec des petits
poils dessus là voyez les les abricot
les pêches les brunons TR ça je suis
allergique et donc donc voilà donc ça
réduit un petit peu le les possibilités
mais les poires il y a pas de problème
et cette saison et c'est un bon fruit et
c'est un bon fruit ouais voilà vous êtes
pas très dessert non je suis pas très
dessert en réalité je suis beaucoup
moins sucré que que salé et donc bah il
fallait bien quand même choisir un
dessert parce que sinon vous allez pas
vous allez pas m'inviter donc j'ai
choisi un DESS et donc l'idée qui est
venue c'est de me dire ben prenons des
fruit de saison voilà ça a du sens et
c'est cohérent par rapport à ce qu'
essaie de faire dans les actes et dans
les assiettes et je trouve que c'est
plutôt sympa en plus de manger des
fruits saison ça oblige aussi à se
creuser les ménages parfis les dessert
de la botte tiramisou panacota tout ça
si mais là j'ai pas voulu faire trop
quoi voy non on aurait pu la faire
100 % italienne c'est comme ça il faut
assumer Tiou c vraiment de nous
emmener voilà sinon les légumes de
saison 5 fruits et légumes par jour on
dit qu'il faut manger vous vous êtes à
peu près dans cette Tiège là B grâce à
Marc que vous avez vu en vidéo oui je
pense que maintenant j'y suis mais
c'était pas le cas il y a quelques
années donc voilà et vous arrivez à
faire manger à vos enfants des fruits
des légumes parce que parfois c'est
compliqué dans les famille euh je comme
tous les parents non c'est la grande
galère évidemment donc c'est la bataille
au quotidien mais ça aide encore une
fois de de plutôt avoir quelques talents
culinaires à la maison parce que ça
permet de il a des astuces
par
exactement qui VO pas passer est comme
tout le monde merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi et bien sûr rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LCP